my name is Monica McCormack and I come
to you from downtown i'm working at nyu
in the office of digital scholarly
publishing where i work for both NYU
libraries and NYU press I'm very happy
to be here today to welcome you to
invisible college that camp as scholarly
society which is the second to last
event in the joint series of events from
the research without borders and the
digital humanities speaker series for
this academic year the final event will
be next week on Tuesday April 10th will
feature Eric waken from Columbia's rare
books and manuscripts department talking
about his digital Civil War project so
we'll give more details about that at
the end as we have them will be working
today with the following format I'll
give a brief introduction and then Tom
will speak and then we'll have time
later for discussion than questions from
all of you and because we're videotaping
the event we're hoping everybody will
stand up and ask questions at the end of
the of Tom's talk using the microphone
in the middle so we can capture on the
video your question so Tom shine felt is
the managing director of the Center for
history and new media which is known as
CH NM and also the research professor of
history at George Mason University he
wears a very large number of hats it's
impressive to read about his ax his
accomplishments he's a historian of
science a public historian and a leading
practitioner of the digital humanities
he received his BA from Harvard
University and an MA and a PhD from
Oxford University he has lectured and
spoken widely on the history of popular
science the history of museums history
and new media and the changing role of
history and society he's worked on both
traditional and digital exhibitions at
places ranging from the Colorado
Historical Society the Museum of the
history of science in Oxford the
Louisiana State Museum the national
museum of american history and the
Library of Congress Tom blogs at found
history and in that blog I think he
really usefully demonstrates his reign
as both in admit as an administrator a
hacker a scholar and analyst of the
digital humanities scene so topics that
he's blogged about include things very
pragmatic things like how to use useful
short bursts of organized activity to
create really useful tools like the one
week one tool project he's written about
how to sustain innovation and innovative
institutions while relying on soft money
he's written about whether the digital
humanities reputation as being nice is a
and collaborative is a reflection of the
fact that the digital humanities are
focused really on method rather than on
theory and he's also written about
larger theoretical questions such as you
know the what he's referred to as the
where's the beef question for digital
humanities when is the digital
humanities going to be able to produce
theoretical advances and how we come and
he's placed that question in really
useful historical context so he thinks
and writes about a lot of things today
he's going to be speaking to us about
that camp the humanities and Technology
camp so I will let him take it from
there well thank you very much Monica so
really a pleasure to finally get to meet
you Thank You Catherine I want to thank
cuz we're on video I'll thank Barbara
who couldn't be here for for putting all
this together how many people have been
to that camp before I good not too many
of you all right so we have fresh meat
that's that's a good thing I do write
and talk about digital humanities now
and again but I the most of what I do at
the center is project management work I
you know make things make software make
make online exhibitions make teaching
resources and I think that camp and in
general that the center has a very kind
of practical pragmatic tradition where
we try to you know get stuff done and
that camp very much comes out of out of
at that pragmatic culture of the center
and so I'll talk a little bit about it
today and maybe hopefully entice some of
you to attend one of the DAC camps that
are gonna be happening happening in the
area over the next 12 months or so I
think they're going to be two or
possibly three new york area that camps
at least so hopefully by the end of this
you'll be convinced so these days when
we talk about things like scholarly
societies scholarly publishing scholarly
communication the word that we most
often hear is this word crisis the
crisis in scholarly communication the
crisis in scholarly publishing the
crisis among scholarly scholarly
societies this this this point of view
was it was on display just this week in
The Chronicle of Higher Ed which started
an article with this with this lead will
disciplinary societies become the
bowling leagues of a Kadeem making
reference to to to Bowling Alone the the
early 2000s thesis about the breakdown
of civic life in America you know I
think that's a you know that that's an
enticing lead people read articles about
gloom and doom and disaster I don't
share that that that gloom and doom
outlook but you know my skepticism of it
shouldn't mean you shouldn't take it to
mean that there's nothing to it
certainly scholarly societies have their
problems their membership is aging
they're having trouble gaining new new
recruits attendance at annual meetings
is by and large down journals which are
a mainstay of their work are facing
competition from new business models new
new digital business models especially
really and for many of these societies
especially societies in the humanities
their finances are really in the tank so
the problems are real but I don't think
these economies these economics these
these market measures tell the whole
story and i think that people working
the smart people working at these
disciplinary societies know this Jim
Grossman from the american historical
association was quoted in that same
article saying that the results of their
research of their surveys and actually a
former GM you grad student who's the
who's can't remember his title but he's
like second at tha rob townsend does a
lot of research on the history of the
discipline the history of history and
also a lot of work on looking at the
state of the discipline today and they
said they do a lot of quantitative
research about the state of history and
the state of their organization and one
of the things that they found is that
their membership and even people who are
you know sort of not have been members
will be members go to the meeting you
know that that there's the kind of the
membership and then there's that that
broader community around it um those
historians think that the aaj should be
doing more or less what it is doing and
so this crisis is it can be taken two
ways one one that you know there are
some real measurable problems with
scholarly societies the other that you
know people generally like these things
and and and so I think what we need to
interrogate then is well if they like
what scholarly societies do but the
scholarly societies are having a trouble
making a go of that we should kind of
take a look at what these societies do
and where that mismatch is happening for
most people the main thing that or
they're kind of most direct contact with
the scholarly society is through the
conference through the annual meeting
right that's where you hand over your
credit card for the
most part you know that's where you book
the plane ticket you you spend the money
and you go to the conference that's sort
of your most direct connection with the
organization for for the big societies
in the in the especially for the you
know the MLAs and the AAAS but even even
for the smaller societies bye bye bye
proportion these meetings tend to be
large meetings you know they attract
lots of people they are infrequent
they're usually once a year they're
located in a very specific place and
time you know it's like San Diego 2012
or you know Austin 2014 they're
expensive very expensive both to the
organization and to the attendee and and
there are a ton of work so you know
these characteristics big infrequent
isolated expensive lots of work you can
see why in a kind of fast moving
information environment those adjectives
are not things that are going to be you
know widely attractive although you know
they people continue to go to these
things so but you can start to see why
those characteristics there's a kind of
mismatch even just there and thinking
about you know what what these
organizations are doing another thing
that these organizations do is they
generally have journals probably the
scholars most frequent contact with the
the organization is through is through
the journal it's the you know it's the
thing that it's not the thing they go to
once a year it's the thing they come
back to over and over again in their
research even if they don't read it
cover to cover when it arrives on their
doorstep they do go back to the articles
to the back issues they do you know look
at JSTOR and all the stuff that's there
you know viewed from this crisis point
of view these journals tend to be rigid
in terms of their format you know they
have they have a short introduction they
have a few ten thousand word essays you
know scholarly are
close then they have some book reviews
you know I mean it's very kind of rigid
in terms of the format they're slow in
terms of time to publication I mean
especially if you consider when the
first idea pops into the scholars head
to the time when the journal arrives on
their colleagues doorstep even affect
you know that colleague maybe in the
next office to them you know that the
time to communicate that idea is
extremely long they're inefficient in
terms of the distribution as I said like
the time to communicate the idea from
one office to the next you know it goes
through in terms of the distribution
channels it goes through like several
middlemen and lots of different kind of
digital formats and even even when it's
an e publication you know I mean it it's
created you know it's created in on
paper note cards then it's put into a
Word document that it's turned into a
PDF and I mean you know lots of these
different stages of kind of inefficient
distribution and you know they tend to
be kind of stodgy in terms of the
content if you just kind of like look at
the landscape of information out there
you know via google search you know some
of the kind of stodgy is you know boring
prose is going to be found in these
journal articles not that the research
isn't good but that it's just it has a
kind of stodgy pneus to it and you know
just just from this crisis point of view
no the last thing the last sort of
characteristic of these scholars
scholarly societies the last way that
you know when Jim Grossman talks about
what we do they do membership and you
know Jim said in that article part of
the value of scholarly societies is a
civic appeal there's no doubt it's the
nature and value of citizenship so they
offer some kind of intangible benefit of
representation or advocacy or community
you know this kind of membership
identity in in in a profession in an
organization you know but viewed from
the point of view of crisis this this
this intangible membership community
identity thing is kind of too weak a
market driver to to make a difference to
this crisis
to the crisis in scholarly societies oh
right the last thing that they do very
well they do committees very well
endless committees right exhausting
committees arrogant committees
ineffectual committees right you know
this is unfair a lot of those committees
do very good work i'm part of several of
these kinds of committees myself but for
the people who don't sit on those
committees and you know even for some of
the people who do it's all too easy to
sort of see the management and
governance structures of scholarly
societies in these negative terms that
these are just these are these these
bodies that do a lot of talking around
problems and don't solve problems don't
offer much they kind of get in the way
so all of these structures all of these
structures of scholarly societies they
start to seem less like what the
scholarly societies were intended to do
and more like overhead right they they
seem to kind of get in the way of what
the scholarly society intended to do
that the structures have taken over the
purpose you know the structures were
created for a purpose and now the
scholarly societies kind of exist not
serve the purpose but to kind of
perpetuate the structures and I think
that's a lot of what people see when
they see crisis and scholarly societies
that's that's what they see knowing very
little about the landscape of scholarly
communication and and academic
organizations when we started that camp
in 2008 although I mean knowing what
kind of every scholar knows from you
know going to the annual meeting and
participating in these Hong committees
and stuff you know this was our
perspective these kind of negative
perspectives this was our perspective
when we we launched that camp in in 2008
that the prevailing activities of
scholarly communication too often served
as functional roadblocks to scholarly
communication that the structures were
getting in the way of the communication
that's sort of what we are prevailing
view point I mean that's actually too
fancy a formulation when we started that
camp we actually kind of started it on a
whim we're a bunch of us especially a
couple of graduate students we were
sitting around the developers table and
thinking that you know these conferences
they carry way too much over you know I
think you know we had been back from a
couple of meetings and just the thought
that these these things carry way way
too much overhead when all people really
want to do is get together they cost too
much money that was kind of the first
insight you know why should it cost an
organization tens of thousands of
dollars even hundreds of thousands of
dollars and certainly cost the
membership hundreds of thousands of
dollar q think of all the money spent on
on an MLA meeting not by just by the MLA
itself but by all the members who spend
you know thousand-dollar plane ticket to
get to Seattle or whatever just the
amount of money that's spent to host one
of those meetings you know we thought
like why should it take that much money
just to get together why should it take
years of planning I mean these these big
meetings some of them are they have to
plant them ten years in advance you know
the book that you book the hotel five
certainly five possibly even ten years
in advance to get you know the hilton in
Chicago in 2020 you know why does it
need to take full time staff when you
like you know you can email a bunch of
people to get you know we all organized
like events right parties and other
things and it doesn't take a full time
staff we get together you know why
should it take 200 page programs why
should it take tote bags all of this
seemed like overhead to to us you know
I'm being really unfair here in the
first part of my presentation I'm going
to be much fair in the second part of my
presentation we also felt that there was
you know sort of too much talking at
these meetings you know these big
meetings and everybody goes to them and
what do you do you know you do this
right someone talks at you and you
listen and you wait and wait and wait
and wait so you can talk at them at your
session
you know that's the that's the model and
we thought that you know why should we
spend so much energy sort of talking at
each other why can't we just kind of get
together to talk about our ideas share
ideas solve problems share work in
progress you can see this is like this
is definitely like dorm room kind of
late night conversation kind of stuff
right this is this is this is this is
how how this happened we also thought in
terms of overhead there's like too much
psychological overhead at these meetings
there's too much tension too much
hostility there's way too much anxiety
for younger members of the profession
and way too much ego for older more
established members of the profession
you know like why can't we all just get
along this was our that this this was
this was our thought and that camps
ground rules which are you know in one
form another or another red at most of
the beginning you know this becomes kind
of theological but they're kind of red
at the beginning of of most fat camps uh
you know reflect these reactions to to
scholarly meetings and I think it's
worth it take take a minute to try to
understand them even if I'm you know and
they're there these ground rules are
really framed in kind of in opposition
to the the values of traditional
scholarly conferences even if that
scholarly conference that imaginary
scholarly conference is something of a
straw man so first of all that camp is
fun right so we set up this idea that
camp this new thing that we're going to
invent that camp it should be fun and
that means you know no reading papers
none of this no PowerPoint like this is
very um that cap and in fact like this
is actually a very fancy room for that
camp and I'm actually you know I'm very
grateful for that you know this is not
the kind of room that that camps
normally held in but you know no
PowerPoint presentations no extended
project demos and no grandstanding you
know none of this pontificating that
that I'm doing right now that camp was
meant to be productive so following kind
of from the no papers rule we're not we
don't go to that camp to listen
and be listened to we go to work we go
to that cam to work to participate to
solve problems to start new projects to
cure writer's block forge new
collaborations whatever whatever work
means to the attendee that's what should
happen at that camp and then that camp
is is is collegial kind of also
following from the fun rule you know
everybody at that camp should feel free
to participate equally that there's no
you know management and staff there's no
full professors and grad students and
associate professors and assistant
professors and adjunct faculty you know
none of those kinds of distinctions
should exist at that camp and there
should be no kind of petty of
the kind where you know after I give my
talk you guys I'll try to pick it apart
and find out where I went wrong and you
know we don't do that we help each other
solve problems you know that doesn't
mean that we all you know you can never
identify where someone has taken a wrong
step but it shouldn't be like you know I
as the speaker prove how smart I am and
then you as the as the audience member
and the QA try to prove how stupid I am
by comparison with you you know that
kind of dynamic we we tried to avoid at
that camp so with those values in mind
we try to imagine a new kind of meeting
and being a digital humanities shop we
took we took a large inspiration from
the culture of Silicon Valley and a set
of bar camps foo camps on conferences
that were that were organized in Silicon
Valley in the in the early part of the
2000s and these were events where they
didn't have preset agenda they they they
they didn't have you know preset
sessions and session rooms it was really
a bunch of interested people would get
you know people who were interested in
in in a set of mutual concerns would get
together they would on the morning of
the event come up with some stuff to
talk about and they would break off into
groups and talk about it and so that
kind of unconference what's you know
come to be known as an unconference and
there are different ways to
on these and everybody's got you know
kind of ideas about which are the best
way to run these in that camps actually
are run in a lot of different ways but
but but the we can kind of put all of
those different ways of running these
these events under this term
unconference that that was the model
that was the model we we chose so in
2008 we we put out a call on the web on
Twitter on our blogs saying to people if
you'd like to come to chm in June and
talk about stuff let us know like and
really we did it by emails like shoot us
an email tell us what you think you want
to talk about and you know book your
plane ticket or you know getting your VW
bus or what you know whatever whatever
your your preferred mode of
transportation is we used rooms at the
university that nobody was using on on
friday afternoon saturday morning and
sunday morning we we hosted 60 scholars
at that first that camp of well 60
scholars librarians other kinds of
people who do digital humanities the
whole thing costs three thousand bucks
we recovered almost all of that through
small donations we literally passed a
hat at the beginning of on Saturday
morning and you know people through in
10 20 bucks whatever they could we
recovered most of that 3,000 that way a
couple of organizations who thought it
was a good idea stepped up and gave us a
couple hundred dollars to pay for
breakfast and so for three thousand
dollars we got 60 people together for
two days of great conversation and a lot
of work getting that we gave them
breakfast and lunch both days that you
don't get that at most meetings we gave
them free coffee as much as they could
drink everybody got t-shirts everybody
got a badge and we were even add enough
money left over to give to student
travel stipends for 3,000 bucks right so
not hundreds of thousands of dollars
three thousand dollars
and sort of to our surprise after we did
another one of these things in 2009 some
of the attendees decided to and really
without any coaxing of ours very
spontaneously some of the people who had
attended that that camp in 2008-2009
decided to host their own and said hey
can we you know use the that camp name
and do one in the first one was in
Austin the second one was in in east
lansing and and so in late two thousand
nine there were a handful of these kind
of locally organized grassroots events
that did the same thing you know found
some rooms came up with a little bit of
money bought some coffee invited a bunch
of people to come and talk about about
issues of mutual concern I mean there
were a couple reasons why this went
viral one is that again its digital
humanities and there's a kind of there's
a kind of it fits you know it fits well
that the openness the happiness the the
the decentralized nature of it it kind
of fits well with the culture and the
ethics of digital humanities you know
the the fact that people in the digital
humanities often had heard of these
kinds of ents before through you know
the silicon valley tradition of bar
camps helped but I think mainly what
made this go viral was the fact that it
didn't cost much it really what it costs
is a very enthusiastic graduate student
I mean somebody who can and somebody
whose whose enthusiasm can attract
participation and then and then a little
bit of money as well but that what it
really takes is is is is some sometime
we say about a hundred hours and
commitment so somebody's got to spend a
hundred hours on this thing and you know
somebody's got to get really psyched
about it to pull it off but other than
that anybody can do one of these and I
think that really the low overhead pneus
of it allowed this thing to to go to go
viral
in in 2010 we got talking to the mellon
Foundation about this thing melon was
interested in providing what Don waters
was calling at the time digital
humanities training at scale he wanted
to figure out a way to train scholars
non-digital scholars in the basic you
know kind of basic training for non
digital scholars in the in the in the
kind of methods of the digital
humanities and he wanted to do this you
know he didn't want to fund you know
give somebody $500,000 to bring a
hundred scholars to a university for
three weeks in the summer and you know
really trick what he wanted to do was
give you know somebody a small amount of
money and figure out a way to train lots
and lots of people in the very basics
and just kind of mapped very well on to
what you know he was talking about this
that we got to talk him as it mapped
very well on to on to what he his aims
were because we had you know a kind of
low cost model and and something that
was was scalable this was something that
was extensible it would prove in that
you know this can this can happen
anywhere for very low low cost even
though we at that time had only had you
know there had been less than ten of
these things probably so mellon gave us
a little bit of money by their standards
a very little bit of money I don't have
to be cagey about it two hundred fifty
thousand dollars for two years to kind
of extend this thing and to add a
training component to it and basically
what that money has that money paid for
paid for three things one developing the
training component to providing very
small five-hundred-dollar travel
stipends to graduate students to go to
these things so that you know pay for
hotel room and gas kind of travel
stipends and then and then most
importantly pay for Amanda French our
regional coordinator to not to run that
camps herself certainly she and she
doesn't run them herself she hasn't a
few in a few cases
but to provide support and guidance and
answer questions and kind of organize a
community she's really kind of like a
community organizer for this group of
people who wants to who wants to run run
that camps and the realization there was
we had kind of created an invisible
College an invisible society of of that
campers that these people this had
become a community and this was
something we this was a community that
we could grow and it was the idea was to
to make that society that college more
visible to to to institutionalize it
just enough so that it could be extended
but not to create the kinds of overhead
that that you know the scholarly
societies in the scholarly conferences
against which that camp really was and
it really was against which that camp
really was originally envisioned so so
where we were you know this is over the
past couple of years last 23 years this
has been a process of making something
which started really as you know
completely spontaneous grassroots or
effort invisible in a way to kind of
make this more visible just visible
enough so that it's sustainable and in
fact we just got another round of
funding from melon it will be our last
another 250 grand our last money that's
that's the last money will get from them
to make this fully self sustaining its
kind of set it off from the nest you
know we we don't want that camp to be a
CH and em thing that camp is really
something that was you know we we had
the idea the community ran with it and
the community should should own it and
so we're going to you know take what has
been something invisible and make it and
make it visible and viable and
sustainable in the community you know
and in doing so we've kind of adopted
the sum of the hallmarks of the
scholarly societies against which we had
originally defined ourselves right like
how we're like you know this is how this
happens things are institutionalized
and and we're becoming institutionalized
but but but what we're trying to do
though is to take on some of the
hallmarks of those scholarly societies
the things that as Jim Grossman said
people want us to do but without taking
on the structures without taking on the
overhead and so a couple of the things
we're doing the conference the annual
meeting I mean really it's just a it's a
structure right it's not an end in
itself it's a it's a vehicle for
face-to-face communication among members
of the profession and so we want to
accomplish that's what the membership
wants quote wants us to do provide a
venue for getting together and so we're
going to try to do this ain't we're
trying to do the same thing but we're
doing it through a hundred distributed
events and we just passed a hundred that
camps there have been a hundred locally
organized that camps around the world
you know we've had our first one in
asia's probably going to come off in
Saigon we've had Australia New Zealand's
not on the map we've had you know half
of the states 20 countries have had
these things so it's really I mean this
is distributed and so I mean what's
great about this the reason why it's
kind of we've been able to do this at
scale um people can go to these things
at first people were like oh how am I
going to get money to get a plane ticket
and get a hotel room in fairfax to the
go to that camp well you know now
there's a that camp near you you know
you you probably don't even need a hotel
room there's one probably within driving
distance of you at this point and or
there's one that's in cats going on kind
of nearby or in conjunction with another
meeting that you're you're probably
attending and so we're actually
piggybacking on that scholarly society
structure but this is another model for
providing face-to-face communication for
vast numbers of vast member you know
vast numbers of members of the
profession right so we don't have to all
we don't bring everybody to San Diego
you bring the conference to them so
hallmark of scholarly societies but
without the structures of how scholarly
societies write the journal again the
journal is a structure it's an
institution but it's an institution with
the goal of you know distributing
high-quality written communication
written written written articles the
journal is not the goal of its not the
journal is not what people want the
scholarly society to do it's they want a
vehicle for the kind of Content that the
journal provides and so instead of a
journal we've had blogs again it's kind
of a more distributed model people blog
in connection with all of the back camps
or most of the back camps they create
google docs collaborative Google Docs as
notes for sessions or accession
proposals on they blog on their own
blogs before and after that camp with
ideas and and other things and you know
some of this is really half-baked some
of it is a more fully baked some of it
becomes more fully baked as as people
think about it and as the conversation
continues after the conference and look
and to to to facilitate that we are and
we can talk about I think we can talk
about this more in the in the QA we're
going to take the best of all the stuff
that's produced in connection with that
camp on all these blogs and Google Docs
and just kind of all over the place
we're going to try to gather this
together provide some kind of peer
review peer reviews probably too strong
a term vetting assessment and to wrap it
up into a kind of journal called
proceedings of that camp but but it's
not going to be a kind of standard
journal with submissions and stuff it's
we're going to go out and find good
stuff out there or have people nominate
good stuff that's out there I'm going to
roll that you know every six months or
so we're going to roll that into a kind
of published volume in connection with
our press forward effort which we can
talk about as well
so kind of this publishing thing that
associations do we're going to do some
of that but without the kind of overhead
of the journal membership again this is
another thing that these another
structure that that scholarly societies
employ what they're really trying to do
is provide community and professional
development for for the members we
provide community instead of a
membership we provide social networks so
the the membership of that camp exists
primarily on Twitter it's the community
of people who follow that camp hashtag
and you know all although that camps we
made a decision early I mean we had
actually a pretty big debate about this
early on whether each that camp should
have its own hashtag or whether
everybody should use the that camp
hashtag we landed on everybody should
use just plain that camp to the extent
on everybody does this is a distributed
community we can't tell people what to
do but but we encourage people to use
just that camp because what that allows
is for people who aren't at you know
that camp luxenberg to kind of follow
what's going on at that camp luxenberg
and so there's always stuff being posted
at the back camp hashtag certainly
there's you know normally at this point
there's a vac camp you know two or three
a month so almost every weekend there's
stuff being posted but even when there's
not at that camp happening people are
posting stuff in connection with that
camp you know things that they've
written after that camp links that
they've uncovered after they've gone to
that camp that relate to something they
were talking about at that camp and so
there's there's there's a there's a kind
of membership a group of people who are
connected by a hashtag and that that and
if that camp is is anything it is a it
is a community I mean it's a membership
and in that way probably more than in
any other side from the conference aside
from the journal that camp is is
becoming more and more like a scholarly
society professional development
in connection with the melon grant we
created a new thing you know that camp
when it first started happened on
Saturday and Sunday morning we created a
new thing called that boot camp which
would was a one-day training program
slightly more structured there would be
there's a there's sort of an agenda
there are instructors who provide four
or five sessions in basic training in in
digital humanities methods again the
curriculum isn't set people that the
organizers can set the curriculum they
can teach the skills they want to teach
or the skills that they have access to
or the skills that they're that their
attendees want to learn about but but we
kind of invented a space this Friday
space for people who wanted to provide
some more structured training so this is
our professional development component
we talked about committees we've got our
committees as well you know it's a very
loose structure right now that camp is
kind of run you know in some ways it's a
benevolent dictatorship with Amanda as
the dictator but she has a kind of
Politburo of camp counselors these are
the people who who organize camps and
they exists on there their primary
interactions are on a listserv where
they ask and answer questions of one
another you know I'm planning of that
camp how do I pay for breakfast I'm
planning at that camp is it better to
use white boards or easels for for
scheduling you know whatever whatever it
is and they guide the kind of direction
of that camp they keep they keep that
camp running they they allow for new
blood for people new organizers to come
in and and and and get and get answers
to their questions and they kind of
maintain the values and the ethics and
the and the practices the kind of
culture of the organization in the same
way that you know
committees and governance other
governance structures in in scholarly
societies do this is sort of centered
around Amanda right now this activity
these conversations she's the moderator
of the listserv in effect it's an open
open list sir but she's she's she's kind
of the moderator she does a lot of
answering the questions we don't want to
be in that position long term as I said
this is our last grant we don't we don't
want to own that camp that camp zone by
the community we want to set it free and
so over the next two years one of the
big things we're going to be working on
is setting up a coordinating council to
take over the management of that camp to
be the governance structure to replace
Amanda as the as the center of this of
this community and that's going to be
made up of mainly you know the real kind
of that camp geeks that the people who
go to lots of that camps and organize
that camps and it's weird there are
people who like travel to these things
it's little it's funny it's like I
thought I had this I had this I thought
the other day it's like it's like dead
shows kind of like there are people who
travel to these things you know there
are people who like you know I I went to
one dead show that was enough for me you
know like I got it and I it was cool and
I like the music but that was enough but
then there were people you know who've
gone to 100 dead shows and and and
that's cool too same with that camp
there are people who go once and say
okay nice and then there are the people
who like travel around and then go to
they've gone to like 20 of them and it's
and and so we're going to try to you
know recruit that enthusiasm for to
maintain to maintain the the
organization in general so while we're
taking on the hallmarks of scholarly
society we're trying to do the things
that scholarly societies want to do and
do the things that the membership of
those organizations value the big
difference is well all while their
operations while the main the big skull
is the traditional scholarly societies
their operations tend to be centralized
ours are all decentralized that's the
big I think the big innovation if
there's an innovation from that camp
it's this decentralized
structure and there's a couple of
analogies you can make you can make two
airline travel routes travel networks
the kind of old hub and spokes model of
United and American and the big old line
airlines to to southwest and airtran and
these kind of ups are jetblue these
upstart airlines the old airlines use a
kind of hub and spokes model the new
ones a point-to-point model so here's
United's route map and you can see like
they you know San Francisco Los Angeles
Denver Chicago Houston those are their
hubs and all of the traffic most of the
traffic goes into and out of those hubs
so if you want to go from you know from
charlotte to los angeles you go through
houston right and you change planes in
houston and that's and that's how it and
that's how how it works this is
Southwest's route map very different
they have all point-to-point flights
they will fly from they will fly from
you see actually it looks like a hub but
it's not it's just that loss of
everybody wants to go to Las Vegas but
if they want you know if if there are
enough people who want to go from
Phoenix to Seattle they'll have a root
going from Phoenix to Seattle and it'll
go direct if there aren't enough people
who want to do that they won't do it but
the key is is that the the relationship
of all these cities to one another is
these are these people these cities are
interested in one another there's only a
route if there's a lot of people in
Houston who want to go to Chicago then
there's a route that camp is very much
like this that that that the
relationships are peer-to-peer there
between the people if the organizer of
that camp Charlotte meets the organizer
of that camp Orlando they have a
relationship it doesn't go through the
hub of Amanda necessarily they can they
can they can organize a that camp on
their own they can answer their own
questions they can do do their own thing
another example of of this and other
analogies is between the the telephone
exchange versus the internet again like
telephone exchange you know the
calls go in this operator puts the you
know connects the call all the calls go
through this go through this operator
versus the internet where you know
there's not one big honking computer
sitting in the Pentagon where all
traffic goes through and somebody you
know flipping switches or pulling plugs
traffic is routed through individual
servers on the network hopefully in the
most efficient way to get traffic from A
to B so it doesn't go through there are
there are these are these are countries
the hubs that I mean there are there are
places where there's more traffic and
less traffic but the traffic doesn't all
go through any kind of central central
hub that camps like that that camp is a
community that has its own relationships
it we have there there really should be
no central office that camp is in that
way web native that camp looks like the
internet and to the extent that to the
extent that that camp is successful on
the internet successful in the Internet
age to the extent that that camp kind of
meets the crisis in scholarly societies
better than some of the scholarly
societies have it's because that camp
works like the internet that camp meets
the challenge of new media sort of
seamlessly organically because it works
like new media new media is not a
problem for that camp it's just the way
that camp works that camp is that camp
is web native I've always said in
running digital humanities projects
building websites the websites that work
are the ones that work the digital
humanities project what they're the ones
that work like the internet the ones
that fail are the ones that fight
against the internet way of doing things
I mean and and it's it you can you can
see a failed project and a successful
project and and most of the time it's
because one tried to fight against the
internet way and the other just adopted
the Internet's values ways of working
you know traffic routing patterns all of
that those are the ones that succeed and
to the extent that that camp has six
in the Internet age it's it's for that
reason I've done a lot of bashing of
scholarly societies and I and I don't
mean to I mean these are invaluable
organizations they they still have a
huge role to play and in fact we spent a
lot of time working with them now oui
oui they are coming to us we're coming
to them to try to you know help them
deal with these these crisises that
these crises that have that the internet
is causing them increasingly the big
scholarly organizations and the little
ones are having that camps they're
adding unconference elements they're
either having that like that camp aaj
like an actual that camp in connection
with the conference or they're adopting
some of these ways of working to try to
meet some of these challenges and we we
we don't want to work with them work
with them to do that we defined that
camp in organized in a position to the
big scholarly conferences but our
intention was never to knock those those
things down those will serve a roll it
but it was just to try to imagine on a
very small scale a new model a new model
that kind of was web native and you know
hopefully we've done that and hopefully
that's a model that that other people
can learn from so thank you and happy
for questions yeah so I'm gonna field
questions and pass them along and please
do remember to use the microphone so we
can capture your question we have some
takers good okay if I can stain hi thank
you Tom I'm mark folsom from CC MTL
center for new media teaching learning
nobody mentioned the digital campus blog
which I really enjoyed listening to you
and I recommend everybody here I guess
question is about the journal part of
that camp and its intended audience as
you think about what this thing will be
and I connect that with some of my
interest in the difficulty in conveying
the work of digital humanities and so
I'm wondering whether the reader of that
journal will be brought into some of
these processes that you're talking
about or it will be sort of an in-flight
magazine for people who are already in
the community and and will it be more
than just sort of snapshots of what
happens in those fertile weekends but
maybe some sort of demonstration about
how that connects to larger projects
that develop over time and have some
sort of impact yeah great great
questions um well the first thing to say
is this thing is in its infancy and we
and the answer to most of those
questions is I don't know but I think
you know we are going to throw a bunch
of stuff against the wall and see what
sticks I think that's that's actually
and that is a very that camp way of
working so initially I think what we're
going to do is because we've got a big
backlog of stuff you know produced from
these hundred camps I think what we're
going to do is we're going to really
just start organizing and putting out
that stuff and by turns we're going to
start opening up so that process I think
is going to be pretty close to begin
with because we want to actually you
know produce something and put it out
there and see what people how people use
it how people want to use it what which
people are using it and then and then to
iterate on it so are our philosophy with
the journal is that we're going to take
a bunch of we're going to find a bunch
of stuff that's good good writing good
stuff that's been produced at that camps
we're going to wrap it up and we're
going to put it out there and we're
going to iterate and we're going to
invite the community whoever that is
initially it will probably be mainly
people who are you know that camp
regulars enthusiasts whatever to to make
suggestions to tell us well you need to
open up your peer review model or you
need to you know your selection model is
wrong or you know or or you know you
need to try to reach a larger audience
and i think so i think that that the
that the proceedings of that camp you
get in august when we we put out our
first issue is going to be very
different from the proceedings of that
camp that you get in say 2013-2014 so
we're going to try to solve those
problems those questions answer those
questions pragmatically
hi I'm and Jonah's from the bernhard
center for research on women and I'm
curious about how in the VAT camps
you've kind of dealt with the tension
between building on what you've already
talked about and kind of not having the
same conversations over and over again
we'll also be able to bring in new
voices and I kind of wonder if you if
you have any best practices for the ways
that you try to do that or if it happens
organically or if you see that tension
or not yeah I mean I I definitely see
that tension the same conversations
happen over and over and over that is
you know every that camp has two or
three conversations about tenure and
promotion I mean you know inevitably so
yeah so they say they do have the same
conversations over and over and over
again I think the first thing to say
about that is in one respect that's not
bad these are conversations that lots of
people want to have need to have and so
you know let let them have them on the
other hand I do see I you know I think
we want new stuff to come out of that
camp we don't want it to just be you
know 2008 you know groundhog day over
and over and over again and so there are
a couple of things that that we've done
I think to to try to encourage that and
I think the big thing is the realization
that we should encourage to kind of
specialized kinds of that camps the
first one being these disciplinary that
camps that are often tied to a big
scholarly meeting so that campeche where
you know they talk about history and
things that are of concern to digital
historians but not necessarily to you
know digital it people or you know that
camp 18th century studies you know that
was another you know so there are these
kind of very kind of specialized back
camps which deal with issues of concern
to a smaller community not the whole
community of d h the second thing we've
done is so
there's there's these disciplinary ones
and then there's somatic back camps and
when we first started this I was really
against this idea I was like no like it
should just be that camp you know it
should just be it should be anybody
should be able to talk about anything
there shouldn't be any constraints on
the on the program and and then I
realized or I was I was schooled that
there still aren't really constraints on
the program you know just because it's
labeled that camp 18th century studies
like the culture of the thing is such
that if somebody starts talking about
you know the 16th century you know no
one's going to get really offended and
and people go and people from outside
those disciplines go so so so the other
thing so so I was against this but but
we've we've also started these so the
Disciplinary ones and then then also the
thematic ones where you know there's a
that camp theory which doesn't make
sense to me because that camps a
pragmatic thing but there's going to be
at Camp theory which is great like and
that's the beauty of that camp people
can if they want to have a strong focus
on theory or that can't pedagogy that
camp games there have been so if people
really want to talk about games there's
that camp feminism's you know so if you
know people want to talk about issues of
gender in particular well great you know
they can do that just so long as it's
open to everybody and nobody's excluded
and you know people aren't going to be
aren't going to be made to feel excluded
because of the Disciplinary focus or the
thematic focus then then that's that's
great and that's worked and so that has
I think helped to kind of focus people's
minds on and do to do new things that
aren't just the same old d.h
conversations that you know everybody's
heard before please make hi hello Bruce
tenets of I at pratt institute and
expect and hope to get my m cells next
month for to be a second career
information professional I'm curious
about the fact i noticed in your slide
of
I don't know if that was the first back
camper and early that camp I'm guessing
that the population was largely junior
faculty and grad students and I'm also
guessing that demographically excuse in
that direction so the question would be
do you see this is having an impact on
the entire system of tenure and
promotion the tendency toward permanent
adjunct faculty does that come up at all
at the bat camps or do you think it's
you know do you think there will be an
impact yeah I mean it's talked about a
lot so first of all the first thing to
say is it skews young that's for sure it
skews a little male and excuse a little
wider it skews less male and less white
probably and a lot of scholarly meetings
but but yeah it still does and and you
know but again like what's nice about it
is we don't have to solve that problem
centrally necessarily we you know there
are you know there's a working group on
diversity in that camp like peep they
just started this group and they're
doing it and they're trying to figure
out ways to encourage more diversity in
that camp you know there's a back camp
historically black colleges and
universities so to try to solve that
that some of that that problem um so so
the diversity thing you know it's it's a
real it's a real real question in terms
of you know diversity in terms of
position and hierarchy and it's a pretty
good mix actually um you know it skews
young I mean I don't you know there
aren't a lot of you know octogenarian
faculty there but there are plenty of
full professors you know in their late
40s type just made full kinds of people
and then there are plenty of adjuncts as
well and and more and more adjuncts than
you get it at maybe a on aaj meeting
where you know their large registration
and you know there's you don't really
need department support to go to a that
camp so there's probably more kind of
adjunct faculty there's also way more
librarians museum professionals kind of
alt ack types you know people who have
lots of training in the humanities lots
of who work deeply in the humanities
think deeply about the humanities but
don't have kind of traditional faculty
positions those people are there to you
know we are trying to break some of the
down some of those hierarchies what we
don't talk about I think that much or
what we what I don't worry about that
much or and maybe I should is trying to
fix the problem of adjunctive fication
through that camp I'm I think we're more
concerned with just saying like you know
everybody working in academia is
valuable everybody working in the
humanities in whatever capacity should
be heard and at that camp you don't have
to worry about your position we're not
trying to like necessarily you know help
you help help you get promoted to to
attend your trap we're just trying to
say that we're but we do try to
recognize that an adjunct is as good as
a full professor
hi Tom just a quick question if are you
aware of any scholar or graduate student
who is actually looking at that camp as
a community sort of doing a research
project around that camp no no that'd be
good I would love to see it yeah no I
don't know of anybody that's a good idea
though any adjuncts I mean I think
graduate students are listening to this
we'd be happy to help you with that I um
my voice is terrible sorry but have a
cold but um thank you for really
thought-provoking talk and and I can't
help thinking looking at the history as
a historian looking at this phenomenon
that you're participating in looking
back as I listen and look at what that
camp is doing it makes me think very
much of something that flourished
greatly during the 1990s which was the
Seth summer seminars I don't know if if
you were thinking about that camp that
is informed at all what you're doing if
you're very familiar with that
phenomenon but what Susan hockey and her
people had dead Rutgers ran for a number
of years it was a little bit more formal
in some ways than that camp but still a
pretty loose community building and of
course it didn't go viral so on one hand
there's that historical precedent and
I'm curious to know what you think about
that and if I can stick in one other
piece for the the current thing I'm
wondering if you've looked at analogous
phenomena yet in a way you talk about
this being an expression of the sort of
culture of the web I can't help thinking
one of my staff members is very active
in Occupy Wall Street Dennis I hear him
talk about the kinds of organizational
principles and methods that they pursue
and as they begin to undertake some
pedagogical activities whether you see
some parallels whether you see this very
much as a as a kind of analogous sort of
phenomenon in terms of the
organizational principles that it's
turning to on the basis of people's
participation in the web yeah so so
there's sort of three things there I
guess that I mean the first one the
first thing to say is that you know
we're in the I guess fortunate position
digital humanities there's an argument
over whether to discipline or not
whatever but we're in the fortunate
position that we're new and that we're
trying to establish our kind of
disciplinary structures now in the
change information environment you know
when these you know when aaha was
founded when when MLA was founded they
were these organizations were founded
and their structures were developed in
response to and and and and in you know
in the information environment they were
the scholarly communication environment
and the needs and opportunities that
they were faced with we're doing the
same thing it's just that you know those
needs and opportunities have changed and
and it's just easier for us to react to
that change so this is a you know I mean
this is a part this is another chapter
in a story of discipline building and
and and so there's a lot of precedent
from the 19th century and from the early
20th century in terms of other kinds of
precedent within the Academy we weren't
we weren't looking at those consciously
when we thought of this but I do think
there is a lot of precedent another
thing I'd point to is like the Berks
conference you know which is is you know
kind of you know or is kind of an
organic thing that grew up and has
become an important structure in a
sub-discipline but which wasn't
necessarily kind of intended that way I
know what the Berks um it's a women's
history conference and it is it you know
in some ways was was started in response
to you know the gendered interactions
that happened at the other big history
conferences and it's become a thing unto
itself in many ways it's like that camp
it's a it's a movement dan Cowan likes
to call that camp a movement like the
Olympics you know and and so it is it is
in a tradition of those kinds of
movements so it's kind of kind of
disciplinary analogies movement
analogies the third thing I would say
though is yes Occupy Wall Street is a
kind of similar phenomena I mean the
values of it I think are you know
there's there's some analogies there
but it's also the way it's organized i
mean it's it's an internet phenomenon
you know is organized again kind of
around a hashtag you know the Occupy
hashtag it it's very distributed you
know the Occupy the governance is this
kind of loose consensus governance so
yes there are a lot of analogies there I
think the analogy we were most conscious
of was to open source software
communities which are organizing very
much the same way communicate via the
Internet very you know kind of rough
consensus is there model for governance
so we were very much aware of those
those communities as open source
software developers ourselves and the
two guys who who really spearheaded this
in 2008 Dave Lester and Jeremy Boggs who
grad students and and and developers at
CH and I'm at the time those guys you
know our members of open source
developer communities and and so that
was very much in our in our minds when
we started so I do think there's there
are a bunch of things that grow out of
internet culture like this I actually
have a question the one that camp that
I've been involved with was was that
camp publishing and so not a scholarly
society model as much as a sort of
professional sort of society so there
were people from university presses
there were people from library
publishing operations that are all very
new and we were more or less trying to
figure out how to use technology how to
learn what we needed to know to do to do
our jobs so it wasn't really about a
discipline as much as a sort of job
structure kind of you know how do we
actually do this and one of the
challenges we face especially as we're
sort of trying to extend this out into
the University Press community is that
because of that camp is web native it
can be hard to bring in people who are
not web native and so those people in
the University Press community who don't
tweet aren't in the gang and it's very
hard to explain to them what's going on
to say oh you're just going to post your
idea on a blog and we're all going to
deal with it when we get there what this
what the schedule is I mean that it's
really hard to to kind of move even
though there's a huge need for this
of loose learning about the technology
that you need at the time that you need
it that's really valuable organizing the
event is challenging when you're not
dealing with net natives yeah so how do
you how do you address that or can you
um yeah it is it is difficult it is it
can I think feel like and we've got you
know we do surveys after that camps a
lot or the counselors do and a pretty
common comment you know it's not
certainly not the majority but there's
always a couple people who sort of say
like I felt like I was in a foreign
country like I just I don't get it um
and I got to be honest we haven't come
up with good ways to deal with that I
would love from your experience to hear
some ideas you know on a very common a
very very common criticism is you know
Twitter we use Twitter we mean as I said
like if if that camp is anything it's a
twitter hashtag like it's a community
that is organized around a twitter
hashtag and so if you're not on Twitter
it can be tough to be part of that
community I think you know we're again
trying to have these these vac camps in
connection with particular groups
particular just sub-disciplines
particular particular topics is one way
we're kind of trying to deal with that
one of the things we're going to be
doing is part of the next kind of two
years in trying to spin this thing off
is we're going to build out the that
camp website so most of the individual
one of the things we did in the first
kind of melon grant was one of the
support functions we did was we set up a
wordpress multi-user instance so that
grassroots organizers wouldn't have to
like have their own server and launch
their owner they could just host the
website which you really need for the
camp on our server we're going to build
that out using the tools that CUNY
Commons in a box is providing to try to
bring a lot of the social network me not
away from Twitter but to deduce to to
have another channel for
social networking that happens on on the
blog so that if you're not on Twitter
you can kind of do it there that's also
going to help with the proceedings
because while the proliferation of
Google Docs and other other products
that people produce at that camp is
great and there have been some amazing
things produced there also hard to track
down so we're trying to kind of roll
some of that into the system so we can
then identify it edit it you know make
it good put it out there so but but yeah
I think this is a real this is a real
product kind of two cultures problem and
and something we we need to crack I said
one more thing I boot camp was kind of
part of that too where you know boot
camp was designed and they were and the
Fellowship's that melon gave and
actually they weren't just for graduate
students they were for well be melon
being melon it was like four people
working at four-year institutions you
know I was like you know if you're at
Columbia fine for Community College no
go but but but you know you you it was
designed to get traditional faculty
graduate students people doing
traditional work to that camp and a sip
of the stipulation of their financing
was they had to go to boot camp so they
had to do the kind of you know here's an
introduction to RSS here's an
introduction to to xml here's an
introduction to you know Oh Mecca they
had to do those training at parts to be
able to go so that was an attempt to
kind of roll in some traditional people
so I attended the publishing that can't
with via Twitter and clearly any number
of people can attend that way is there a
natural limit to the physical that camp
at does it get too big um yeah so for we
sort of say the optimal size is between
50 and 75 / 75 yeah it's it gets
really hard to manage that camp the one
at sea H&M which has been called that
camp Prime that camps H&M we're now
we're moving to a convention where we
just named use Roman numerals like the
Super Bowl so it's going to be back camp
v-back camp five that one is bigger that
one's going to be probably close to 175
this year and you know we we can do that
because we you know our kind of expert
doing these things now but if you're
trying to run your own I would try to
keep it to 50 or 60 to be safe yeah
sorry this is just a you meant at the
beginning that you're going to talk
about some upcoming back Kemp's around
here I don't believe that came up so I
was hoping Yeah Yeah right so there's
yeah okay so if you wanna figure out
let's see what's coming I mean that this
is like I really do not know over here
where the back camps are going to be but
they're all these are up coming back
camps and then there's then all the
archived ones are below so there's one
at Penn and the University of
Pennsylvania doesn't mean you can only
go if you're from the University of
Pennsylvania but museums NYC there's one
in Buffalo then there's one in October
that camp theory is going to be at
Rutgers so and there's one and one
Lehigh so there's you know there's a
bunch and then bought there's Boston
there's going to be a back camp New
England I believe again so like there's
probably in the next year six or seven
in you know in dry good driving distance
yeah I wanted to go to Luxembourg I
wanted to go to Florence we made the
mistake of not building travel money
into our melon budget so we don't
actually get to go to any of these
things but I guess that's appropriate
for a distributed event anyone else well
there are still refreshments at the back
so we can have a casual conversation